so we've got an update from South Africa
for you according to news reports the
South African government has withdrawn
its farmland redistribution bill less
than a week after we on this show
reported on the story the South African
government hated our segment and said so
they also hated president Trump's
response to what he tweeted out a
response
they'd been counted they'd counted on
not being criticised particularly from
America the story though is far from
over politicians in South Africa are
still planning to seize land without
compensation on racial grounds in fact
it seems to be underway South African
media report that one of the first
farmers on the list is a man called
Johan Steenkamp he owns a Game Preserve
now apologists for the South African
government and there are many in our
media say that the point of seizing land
is to redress historical injustice --is
and there have been a lot of those in
South Africa but that doesn't apply here
at all and in a lot of these cases but
specifically this one it does not apply
Steenkamp didn't steal his farm from
anyone in fact he says he bought it
legally 21 years ago that's significant
because 21 years ago a party was over
Nelson Mandela was president at the time
but the government is taking it away
from him anyway because he's the wrong
color
Western liberals support this Barack
Obama supports it so does British prime
minister Theresa May so there's pretty
much our entire ruling class and our
news media they are all in favor of
collective punishment based on race and
that is the wheel story to hear a story
here much bigger than what's happening
in South Africa the West's response to
it it's terrifying